the occasion of first vice-president
Timmermans visit to Colombia gives us
the chance to really survey all of the
major challenges facing Europe today
from the refugee crisis which is
literally on Europe's doorsteps on
Europe's railway station platforms all
over Europe at this moment through to
the problems of the euro zone of Greece
the threats in the eastern Mediterranean
and of course the new instability in the
east and the challenge of Russia and
Ukraine the challenge we face is first
of all the international context how
would you bring about peace in Syria is
going to be a big global challenge to
everyone second challenge is how do you
make sure that the money available for
people in refugee camps actually arise
there and creates opportunity for people
who live there third challenge is to get
every single member state to do what
they need to do in terms of
fingerprinting people when they arrive
processing them correctly making a
distinction between refugees and
migrants helping other member states if
they get into trouble because too many
people arrive there those are our main
challenges we need to do a better job at
protecting our external borders we need
to better job at creating peace in the
Middle East me to better job at making
sure that people living in refugee camps
in Jordan Syria and Turkey live on the
acceptable conditions that their kids
can go to school that they can find jobs
so that they can make sure that the
livelihoods are guaranteed we've
mobilized money for all of this we're
going to invest in all of this and I'm
sure that if we do this right and every
single member said the European Union
pulls their weight will get a grips on
it and we'll make sure that next year
the refugee crisis will be faced with
policies that work